new at noon Kansas City Police and the  NFL are investigating Las Vegas Raider  Devonte Adams for assault it's for that  post-game shove as he left the field at  Arrowhead Stadium last night here is  video of that shove Adams knocking down  a TV production assistant after the game  well the assistant went to the hospital  and called police Adams addressed to the  incident afterwards and apologized  Iran I jumped in front of me we were  coming off the field and I bumped into  him and kind of pushed him and then they  end up on the ground so I want to say  sorry to him for that because that was  just frustration mixed with him running  and literally just running in front of  me and I was shouldn't responded that  way  now the NFL says Adams could be  suspended as we mentioned it's being  investigated we'll have much more on  this story coming up at four